Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker gave fans
plenty of answers to long-burning questions,
but it didn't end without leaving a few mysteries
unsolved, one of which involved two of the
sequel trilogy's most important characters.
Major spoilers ahead for The Rise of Skywalker.
In the last journey through the galaxy far,
far away within the Skywalker saga, Rey heads
out with Finn, Poe Dameron, Chewbacca, C-3PO,
and BB-8 in search of a Sith wayfinder, which
will guide them to the desert planet Exegol
within the Unknown Regions.
They encounter danger on the way as Kylo Ren
continues to Force-sense --and effectively
stalk - Rey.
Following a lead on the planet of Pasaana,
the Resistance fighters race away in the general
direction of the long-forgotten ship of Sith
loyalist Ochi of Bestoon.
Having barely managed to shake off the chasing
stormtroopers as they head out into the desert,
the group's speeders are ultimately hit and
blasted to pieces.
Then, they all start to sink into a quicksand-like
substance.
"Ahhh s---, quicksand.
Ah dang, now we are in trouble."
Believing this may be his last moment before
death, Finn calls out to Rey, wanting to tell
her something important.
Before he can say it, though, he sinks beneath
the sand.
While Rey later asks Finn what he wanted to
say - and Poe tries throughout the rest of
the film to press the issue and uncover Finn's
secret - the former Stormtrooper brushes them
off, leaving the audience without an answer
even after The Rise of Skywalker ends.
What was he going to say?
He was sinking into the desert, so maybe he
just wanted to tell Rey how he didn't like
sand, because it's coarse and irritating and
it gets everywhere.
Okay, probably not.
The prevailing theory among fans seems to
be that Finn wanted to confess romantic feelings
towards Rey.
However, Finn actor John Boyega took to Twitter
to refute that particular theory, writing:
"No...
Finn wasn't going to say I love you before
sinking!"
Realistically speaking, a romance between
Finn and Rey wouldn't have made much sense
at all, with Finn and Rose Tico having a hint
of a romantic thing in The Last Jedi and with
Rey and Kylo Ren experiencing a ton of emotional
tension.
"Do you have something, a cowl or something
you could put on.”
With a ton of fan theories running rife, The
Rise of Skywalker co-writer and director J.J.
Abrams decided to clear the air surrounding
Finn's big reveal that never actually came
to fruition in the film.
According to Twitter user Kaila Ren, Abrams
revealed that Finn's secret is something astute
fans may already have guessed: Finn is Force-sensitive,
just like Rey.
Ren posted in a tweet:
"JJ said it meant to him that he wanted to
tell Rey he was force sensitive, but purposely
left it open ended."
Games Radar also reported that Abrams added
the open-ended nature of Finn's secret so
it, quote, "could mean different things to
different people."
We're not entirely sure why this was a secret
that Poe wasn't allowed to know, but Finn
certainly wasn't going to share the info with
his Resistance co-General even with all his
ribbing.
As we mentioned, Finn's Force-sensitivity
is something that's hinted at throughout the
entire Star Wars sequel trilogy - but most
prominently throughout The Rise of Skywalker.
In the film, he was be able to sense when
Rey was in danger, was somehow able to pick
out exactly which of the Star Destroyers of
the massive Final Order fleet was the command
ship, and felt Rey briefly die after she defeated
Emperor Palpatine.
Even before all that, Finn was able to break
free from the extensive brainwashing stormtroopers
are subjected to in the First Order, which
is something CinemaBlend points out as further
evidence of Finn's Force-sensitive nature.
Overall, this is a much better explanation
than the fan-favorite one of Finn wanting
to confess his love for Rey, as it ties into
everything we know about Finn.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.